yeah chris exactly the wnba season may
be on hold for now but for a majority of
aces it will be business
as usual and it might seem a little
premature to say that today's win
was the biggest of the season but for
the aces when you
look at all the implications avoiding a
three-game losing skid heading into a
34-day break
for both the all-star game and the
olympic games as you mentioned today's
double-digit win
over dallas has set the tone for vegas's
return
in mid-august and possibly another deep
run in the postseason
it seems like a dumb statement but that
was a very important game for us the
aces
picked up the big time 16 point
statement win over dallas earlier today
to avoid dropping three straight so we
lost two in a row
now we're on the road against a young
team and it was important for us to get
this victory i thought you know as tom
was set by asia obviously
the reigning league mvp asia wilson led
the way
dropping 22 points to go along with 13
rebounds in a career-high
eight assists you know asia really found
the open
open players today she they
double-teamed her as much as they could
and she was very patient didn't force
things and found open shooters hence the
eight assists
so now the aces take a much needed
extended break
because of both the all-star game and
the olympic games
their next game isn't until august 15.
now you know we get to break with the
break is really going to help our ball
club
in many ways a little oil mentally tired
at the moment
really did a lot of pushing uh this
first half of the season
now we've got a bunch of u.s team puam
on the three on three i hope jisoo
you know shows who she is with her
korean next team all the bob and liz do
and so we got through it and um we go to
the second half so after picking up 15
wins in the first half of the season
what is bill expecting from his team
when they're reunited to make a deep
postseason run well i think we know each
other pretty well right now
i think we can always get better
defensively but we're not a very you
know we're pretty solid defensive team
rebounding uh and they're starting to
understand the value of two points so
you know the
the end will be in sight at that moment
when we come back
uh you know we only have 11 games to
play so it's not you know you know
you're where the finite situation and
the playoffs are going to be
now it becomes seating and go and try to
win every game we play
so now the first half of the season is
all said and done the aza's
15 wins is the second best in the league
none other
than behind the seattle storm with 16
wins
chris is there a rematch brewing of last
year's final of course between
seattle and vegas i guess we'll just
have to wait and see
well certainly exciting to have these
two teams right on top and it'll be a
big game this weekend and kevin you will
be there i know on wednesday
to provide more for us on that big
all-star game hey still